I would request this right now and I
know no one's going to do it because our
politicians are all cowards I'm giving
no no respect and no benefit to any
Republican because none of them will do
it I want them to take a single officer
from that photograph get their name
plaster it in Congress and say I am
coming for you I am going to take from
you your pension and your retirement and
I want your family to know it's because
you refuse to uphold the law if you come
into this office if you put on that
badge and say outright it's someone
else's fault I won't do my job I will
make sure you lose everything because if
you don't want to do your job this job's
not for you you can resign right now no
one's going to do it no one's going to
do it conservatives are going to keep
looking the boots of these cops who who
bashed them over the head during coven
and who refuse to enforce the law to
protect our justices if the judges can't
issue rulings because they're under
threat of death there can be no justice
and these cops are going but it's not my
fault I was told not to enforce the law
okay then get out fire them rant over